leaving Neverland is also shedding light
on why people who say they are child sex
abuse survivors may not come forward and
it's prompting many parents to discuss
how they can protect their own children
in the film Wade Robson explains why he
waited more than two decades to accuse
Michael Jackson of abuse
Jackson has always denied similar
allegations it is estimated that one in
nine girls and one in 53 boys are
sexually abused or assaulted by an adult
dr. veronik Valliere is a clinical
psychologist with more than 25 years
experience working with offenders and
survivors of child sexual abuse
she has also trained prosecutors and law
enforcement on how to interview the
victims and she joins us at the table
really good to have you doctor I should
thank you I had you on speed dial
last weekend because I had a lot of
questions about what is a proper way to
interview the victims and I thank you
you were very very helpful to me
I appreciate it you know one of the
things that you pointed out was that the
Wade and James and most sexual abusers
or many of them take some time to come
forward and they will lie on the stand
as these boys admitted that they did
when they were younger and they will lie
to their parents even after the parents
asked them repeatedly who are not
surprised to hear that oh absolutely not
I mean when you think about it know is
the easiest lie to tell first of all but
second of all the layers of choice to
protect are very deep with victims
there's a self-protection of shame and
blame they may feel responsible or
culpable for the abuse especially if the
offender grooms them was saying you know
this is our secret we'll go to jail
you said it's harder for boys in
particular - right Wow well especially
back when Michael Jackson was being
accused homosexuality was more shameful
and so there's things that go with boys
including they're not socialized to talk
about vulnerability or they have a
greater sexual response a lot of their
sexual abuse doesn't hurt and produces a
sexual response in the child which can
be very confusing I'm reminded of Valeri
Nasser scandal - essentially when this
doctor was abusing these children - some
of them were doctors themselves the
parents and the question is how do
parents not know
and how do parents look for the warning
signs that their children are being
abused even by someone in powerful that
they respect well that used to be a
question for me and struggle for me when
I first started this work with offenders
but when I finally understood how deeply
skilled they are at exploiting and
weaponizing things that we consider
human like care and trust and hope and
niceness they they exploit all the
things that we consider make us good
people right you say beware the power of
nice right what do you mean what do you
mean nice is an extremely powerful
weapon it's very controlling it if you
don't reciprocate in niceness it makes
you the problem if you're not nice back
and it also we attribute a lot of
character traits and and things like
kindness and honesty and truthfulness to
niceness
when nice is a very superficial behavior
Michael Jackson was such an
idiosyncratic character but as Nora
points out in the u.s. gymnastic
situation you also have it in the
Catholic Church so how do parents not
just recognize but God you know talk to
their children to keep this from
happening in the first place well what
first of all pay attention if someone's
paying too much attention to your child
don't don't be starstruck by that kind
of attention and don't let somebody
isolate your child look for presents
that aren't explained or reluctance with
your child to communicate with you or a
change of attachment but most of all if
understand that parents can be groomed
just as well I mean they can be
manipulated they can be tricked and if
your gut is telling you something's off
something's off don't talk to yourself
out of that as well as I'm sorry if we
need to educate kids about what what's
healthy in terms of sexuality and when
to say yes and what and give them agency
over their body and not treat sex like a
dark secret because that pervades their
ability to come talk about it to us I
was just gonna ask you about that
because one of the things we heard from
both of those accusers was they just
didn't know anything they didn't
understand what was happening with their
body so they didn't know that that was
wrong when should parents start talking
to their children about their bond
and about some feelings that they might
start having what is considered a good
age well I think children on up need to
learn the right words for their body
parts so when they tell no one's
confused they need to not be forced to
hug people they need to learn how to
respect sexuality and intimacy and the
choices in the and the difference
between privacy and secrecy we also have
to rid ourselves of this narrative we
have about sexual abuse that it's
violent and frightening and an easily
identifiable because even adult victims
of sexual assault often do not know they
were sexually assaulted because it
doesn't meet their narrative of what
rape or assault and they keep going back
to their abuser - that was another thing
why how do you explain that while they
form an attachment a true attachment of
love and and we forget that the abuse is
only a component of the overall
relationship so the offender may provide
them other things like feeling special
feeling loved giving them gifts all the
things that would require a loss of the
of the individual if they tell these are
such helpful tips and discussions and we
should also note too that I think
pediatricians are required starting at a
certain age to have this discussion
alone with the child to ask them if they
are being touched inappropriately by
state people that is and it's important
I asked but it's also important to
recognize the barriers to disclosure
even in the message even with a new
doctor that they trust good point
dr. Veronique Valle a thank you thank
you the national sexual assault hotline
is available 24/7 for anyone who needs
it and that number is